why isn't anyone doing anything to stop
the war in Syria well maybe because so
many countries are involved in the
fighting let's start on the ground the
Syrian army is supported by Russia which
sends troops and weapons and Iran which
has sent military advisers there also
backed by militias from the region like
the Lebanese Hezbollah or the Iraqi
ofwell fatherland Abbas brigades on the
other side rebels have received training
cash and weapons from Turkey Saudi
Arabia Jordan Qatar the UAE and the US
in the air the Syrian government has
carried out thousands of attacks against
rebel-held areas meanwhile the US UK
turkey UAE Jordan France and Saudi
Arabia have all carried out airstrikes
against another side in the war Isis and
Turkey has also bombed Kurdish targets
inside Syria so is it any surprise that
the war shows no signs of ending anytime
soon
[Music]